As we said before, we'll be using template HTML to build our awesome resumes.
>> To do so, we'll be using the string.replace method to find a pattern
in a string and replace all or some matches of it.
We'll be using the most simple version to find the first instance of a pattern,
but you can do much more.
Check the instructor's notes for more details.
>> Let's take my email address as an example.
If I wanted to change out my Udacity email address for
a Gmail email address, I could use a replace function.
In this case, I've got var newEmail.
It goes email, the string with my Udacity email address and
I'm replacing Udacity with Gmail.
>> And don't forget to check to see if that worked.
>> Right.
Let me add console.log email to see my old email address and
console.log(newEmail) to see my new email address.
Okay, we're going to refresh our page, open up the console and there we go.
We can see my old udacity email address showing up on the console as well
as my new Gmail address on the console as well.
>> Let's have the students try it but
this time, let's append the new message to the page.
I want you to create a new called funThoughts where you take
everything that was in awesomeThoughts, but replace the word awesome with fun.
Use .append(funThoughts) and put it on the page.
Check this box when you see your message show up on the page.